as we get closer and closer to the end
of the year we wanted to remind you
again that we have 2023 microcosmos
calendars available at
complexlycalendars.com they're filled
with beautiful photos taken by our
master of microscopes James Weiss and
each page has information about the
organism on display so you know what
you're looking at each month so if you'd
like to have beautiful microbes on your
wall all through 2023 make sure to head
over to complexlycalendars.com and pick
yours up today
sometimes our journey through the
microcosmos feels like an expedition a
voyage filled with deep dives into the
masses of organisms basking under the
glow of our microscope
but at other times this journey feels
like one big game of hide and seek one
that microbes have been winning in part
because for Millennia we didn't even
know we were playing microbes had
managed the ultimate trick of being
ubiquitous and yet completely hidden
from our view
thanks to the microscope we've managed
to level the playing field a bit
rendering them and their world visible
and with patience James our master of
microscopes has become pretty Adept at
finding microbes in all sorts of unique
locations in fact it feels almost like
the tides have shifted in this game of
hide and seek as if it's impossible for
microbes to truly hide from us anymore
when we peer through the microscope it
seems like we should always be finding
something
so what does it mean when you don't find
anything when you gather your samples
and excitedly prepare them for the
microscope only to find a landscape
lacking in the life you expected to find
that's the question that James faced
recently after receiving samples from a
very interesting place the bottom of a
Norwegian fjord
the researchers who sent James the
samples are studying the jellyfish that
live in the fjords but of course the
organisms he was interested in were on
the much smaller side of things
fjords are the result of ancient
glaciers that carved out valleys and
filled them with water the water and
fjords can run very deep sometimes on
the order of thousands of meters and the
Steep Cliffs that run along the sides
add to the sense that you're suspended
in the middle of a world that is immense
compared to you as small as we are
compared to these depths and Heights
there is a tinier World buried in all
this one that James was excited to see
when he received around 30 tubes of
sediment samples gathered from depths
ranging from 50 meters to a crushing 1
300 meters
but when James opened the first tube he
had to contend with something unexpected
there was no water in the sediment and
when he went to dig into the samples
they were relatively Barren with only a
few organisms appearing this might not
surprise you after all these are cold
dark Waters conditions that should make
it hard for organisms to survive let
alone Thrive yet here we are talking
about fjords and there are several
minutes left in this video so surely
James found something right
yes yes he did this is our tour through
the depths of a fjord told in microbes
let's begin with the first 200 meters of
the Fjord the area called the sunlight
zone as you might guess from that name
this is an area with light making it the
ideal zone for organisms that rely on
sunlight to dry photosynthesis like the
beautiful diatoms in the Arctic fjords
of svalbard these surface waters are
usually shaped by melt water that comes
from glaciers as well as runoff from
Land making them lower in salinity
compared to the water beneath them as
you dive deeper you can see some of the
remains from organisms that prefer those
upper Waters like these frustrials that
came from sediment samples taken at 322
meters deep
placing them in the area called The
Twilight Zone this region starts at
around 200 meters deep and goes down to
around 1 000 meters deep and while some
photons are able to penetrate these
Waters they're not enough to guarantee
the survival of photosynthetic organisms
but that doesn't mean other creatures
can't find a way to survive like these
for a minifera
and descending Beyond The Twilight Zone
takes you to yes you guessed it the
midnight zone there's no light here just
dark and cold Waters that at least in
small Bard accumulates salt released by
sea ice
again we find some of the frustrials
left behind by diatoms that lived in the
sunlight zone but we also find more
unusual sites like this thing which we
think is a tube built by a tube worm
running almost a centimeter in length
the tube was assembled from bits and
pieces of sponge specules and four
minifora shells it's like a collage
crafted out of other Fjord microbes
telling us more about what else lived in
those Waters
it's fascinating but not surprising to
find the populations of microbes
changing as you dive deeper into the
water after all microbial communities
are shaped by light temperature salinity
and other factors in all sorts of bodies
of water whether we're talking about a
fountain a puddle a pond or a fjord we
all have preferences for the types of
conditions we want to live in and
microbes are no different with that said
there was one creature that we seem to
observe at every depth of water in fact
it was often the only living thing James
could find can you guess what it is
foreign
it is none other than the nematode and
perhaps that shouldn't be so surprising
they are after all one of the most
abundant organisms on the planet and
interestingly the nematodes that James
found from the deeper parts of the sea
had little structures in their bodies
that looked like oil deposits though
we're not exactly sure what they are or
what their function might be
perhaps today we've managed a few small
victories in this ongoing game of hide
and seek but there are connotations to
these games that extend beyond just
simple curiosity and joy the microbes
that live in these fjords are part of a
complex ecosystem they cycle elements
like carbon sulfur and iron and they
serve as food for other creatures
so as glaciers Retreat due to climate
change these communities will have to
contend with the shifting landscape the
way water circulates through the Fjord
could change bringing different
nutrients to the surface or a lifting
sediment that blocks more light or it
may bring some other complication for
these microbes that we can't yet
anticipate scientists are seeking out
and studying the microbial communities
and fjords so they can better understand
what these changes will look like to
decipher what survival and adaptation
looks like at the microbial scale and
how that translates to the world we
experience
because microbes Will Survive they've
survived plenty of extinctions already
adapting to the new worlds that arise
and shaping them for the evolving forms
that join them
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
and speaking of surviving the reason
this channel can survive is thanks to
the people you're seeing on the screen
right now these are some of our patreon
patrons the people who have decided to
directly support this channel over at
patreon.com journey to micro and we
thank them so much for their continued
support
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss and why
wouldn't you check out jam and germs on
Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby